David deal Sirius XM NFL WFAN radio host
Fox Sports analyst part of the Giants
broadcast team he won two Super Bowls
with the Giants and David back on the
program David good morning why are they
benching Eli now you know what it was a
interesting day yesterday when all the
news broke and you know at some point
that you know this is going to come to a
head and there was going to be a
transition at the quarterback on and
away from Eli Manning and that's the
history of when you draft a quarterback
and the first round when you figure
since 2008 there's been thirty two
quarterbacks drafted 15 started by week
124 by week five and only six of them
didn't start a midpoint that was Tim
Tebow Jake laughs Euler Johnny Manziel
Jared Goff Patrick mahomes and Lamar
Jets and then figure the only two that
redshirted were Jake Locker behind that
Hasselbeck and Patrick balls behind Alex
list so you know when you draft a
quarterback within the top five six big
especially in the first round
odds are they're going to play their
first year but when you sit there and
you do it after two games number one eli
is not the one who gave up 63 points on
the defensive side of the ball and
number two it's not sending your team
and the Lockland the right message of
you're still trying to be competitive
and play four this year because we know
that when you put in a working
quarterback regardless of the upscale
and up circuit that Daniel Jones had in
the preseason it's a lot different when
you get in the regular season preseason
you're not getting rolled coverages
you're not getting disguises you're not
getting blitzes and I mean Monday night
was a perfect example of a second-year
quarterback of number one overall pick
and Baker Mayfield and what Greg
Williams was able to disguise in the
back end and the issues that it gave him
as a quarterback so I truly believe that
this was a a pitch to basically keep
Giants fans in the stadium my birthday
was on Sunday for the bills game and
they did not give me a present watch the
leverage when you looked into the stands
in the fourth quarter
giant saves were leaving and that's been
that when you are a head coach a general
man as much as you say you don't pay
attention to it you're doing when you
have this type of move of knee-jerk
reaction you know this is the response
that you're gonna get if you were still
on the team what would you say what
would you do I mean obviously I would do
my job and I would protect and do
everything I could to get Daniel Jones
to be successful and it puts a lot more
onus now on the offensive line to be
able to identify blitzes being able to
change the Michael and the middle
linebacker to do those things to help
them out but essentially you're thinking
well we're playing for 2020 right now
you got say Quan Barclay here that's
your that's your lone weapon on offense
defense and he is not being utilized
whatsoever in the way that he should why
fact that we're sitting here over the
first two weeks and he's only had 29
touches total that's the strength of
your football team you go back and you
look at Adrian Peterson Ezekiel Elliott
in their second season throughout the
first two games they had 40-plus carries
let alone when you can slow down a pass
rush with the screen to an elite back
like say Quan Barclay you have to
utilize and that was one of the things
that Giants did not do up against the
Buffalo Bills because figure no golden
tape no Sheppard because of the
concussion then you're looking on them
as a defense saying we're taking Evan
Engram out of this game you're one lone
weapon is take one Barkley and you have
to use and if you plan on winning the
game so that's something that I still
don't understand what do you do if
you're Eli now I think Eli is going to
be himself like the man that he always
is he doesn't wear his emotions on its
leaves and you know that he's going to
prepare like he is a starter and he's
going to do whatever he can to help
Daniel Jones
make the progress needed but having said
that you know that he's pissed off that
he's not starting this weekend because
truly it was it his fault that they lost
the first two games does he not have a
better chance of beating the Tampa Bay
Buccaneers and next week the Washington
Redskins and Daniel Jones
absolutely and when you think about this
now
on the road in Tampa up against Todd
Bowles in that defense you know he's
going to do all different types of
disguises blitzes and trying to get
after a quarterback and then on the
opposite side of the ball you know Bruce
Arians is wicking his job because his
whole goal and objective is to make
Jameis Winston and prove that he still
is an NFL starter do you know that this
was a tough environment to go into and
you know he's going to see things that
he's never seen before yeah I'm
surprised at this I mean I understand
that you don't want to lose your fan
base and if you say to your fan base hey
the future is Daniel Jones in the future
is now I understand it I do think the
Giants made a mistake by bringing Eli
back this season but I couldn't agree
with you more if this was the case and
the lease was only going to be two games
then you should have let him go during
the offices and then let him go
someplace where he would play this
season because that's the whole thing is
it almost feels like it was disingenuous
one of the saying oh he's got a lot left
in the tank so he's gonna play a lot of
football we'll make the transition when
we feel daniel Jones is ready
well that's not what you guys did do you
think Eli is a hall-of-famer I do I'm
without a doubt - I mean yep
championship - Super Bowl and the step
people how about did he has as many
postseason wins that Steve Young ate how
about his hundred and six completions in
the 11 playoffs are the most in NFL
history 5 gaming winning drives in the
postseason that's just as many as Joe
Montana and Terry Bradshaw four
fourth-quarter comeback to the
postseason that's just as many as John
Elway and 210 consecutive starts I don't
think anybody's going to be able to
touch those for a long time David great
to talk to you as always always
appreciate your passion certainly with
this topic and I know you know pretty
close to home there with Eli and what he
meant to you and got a couple of Super
Bowl rings that you wear because of him
so thanks for joining us my pleasure and
quit being sick and tired of being sick
and tired
thank you David that's a David deal got
a couple
Super Bowl rings Fox Sports analyst part
of the Giants broadcast team for more
Dan Patrick show tune in the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV stream for free
on BR live or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]